Why. Right.
You as an m b in g double e to.
Bob this it. T i double s o double t.
Well i first came here. Hi my name is bob.
Tippett
and i first came to nimbin about six weeks
before the aquarius festival with two
close friends
and we were coming up to
help get the site organized
and we were driven by the idea
that the incredible string band we're
going to be playing which they never did.
For the six weeks prior to the festival.
My main job was working in the rainbow
cafe which was cooking breakfast lunch
and dinner for the workers.
If you're a worker putting together the
site you were paid one nym buck per day
and one number was enough to buy
you breakfast lunch and dinner.
Which usually consisted of porridge for
breakfast and fried vegetables for dinner.
Lots of veggies
and rice is a very macrobiotic time.
At the same time i unfortunately was
apprehended for the cultivation of marijuana
which resulted in all the other people
who were working on the fence was like
putting on a benefit concert
to try to raise the bail so
that i could get out of jail
that we would have to spend a week in
the lismore lock up waiting for the
magistrate because i only had
one day a week. And we got.
After on the same day
that they had caught so we had a wait
till following week to get to see him.
And they had a wonderful benefit dance.
They made no money but every
had a wonderful time. Yeah.
So after that i are i went to
sydney for a few months following
that to earn the money to cover
the bail but a friend a toad
and then came back up
and rented another farmhouse over on
stone issued road where i lived for
i suppose six months.
With maybe six other people
in the big old house at
that time nimbin ji had been purchased
by the original group of people who are
got it together and there
was still shares for sale.
So i promptly went back off to sydney to
work to earn enough money to buy shares.
Which i did
and arrive back up here in my 1977.
My memories of the festival.
I think my strongest memory of the
festival was the visual impression of it
when you look from the main street
of limon down into the paddocks
that are behind the hotel.
And it looked like an army camped
out for the night in some medieval
battle there were hundreds of
little campfires everywhere.
There was missed it was in the
middle of winter heavy mist.
So you could just see
these glows of the fires
and the smoke in the mist
combined so that you
when you're actually in the site area
in the camping area of an evening.
You couldn't see more than 15 20 feet
in front of you which was really rather
exciting.
When you're walking around you sort of
bump into all these rather interesting
and amazing people.
I remember the the public access stage in
particular too in terms of if you want to
get on stage
and do something in front of a whole lot
of other people you just had a write your
name down on i. On the
schedule and i'm blank spot.
And there was lots of.
I think of our people music as well a
lot of rhythm a lot of drumming people
bongos and logs and
anything you could shake.
I mean still goes on today i was in town.
Only yesterday
and the african dance group had the whole
of town just something with this constant
within it was wonderful.
A lot of religious groups at the first of
all i mean the christians were perhaps
the most visible they had
a really large marquee.
But there were maybe half a dozen different
religious organizations set up their
their tents and ply
their spiritual trades.
The hari tent. Well there was are.
A free feast every lunchtime.
If you are hungry very much into their
whites sugar sweets lots of very sweet food
a lot like a sugar. But anyway if
you are hungry you can go along.
They always get a meal they are they had
a 24 hour chanting session on buddha's
birthday which was on the
full moon in taurus.
It was celebration of
the birthday of buddha
and they chanted from midnight to midnight
without cease there's always somebody
working at it and a lot of
people during that process.
Twenty four hours ago and join
in and chance of happening.
Our work and self into a frenzy get hungry
and most of the off somewhere else.
I think a lot of people
see the. One of the.
Right things i had a come to grips with
that was a toilet situation which was.
I circle of perhaps. 4 4 foot high.
They had a whole circle inside of it.
Of dunnies and when you went and you said
i dunno you are fighting perhaps seven
or eight other people who are also sitting
on their dunnies and you could smile
and you could chat over the little
partition between your dna in the next
and he was quite a social
place overall the dunnies.
Not quite a social is a soreness
of course which were very social.
Very socially there was
too soon as there was one
that was built out of corrugated iron and
people got burned bombs in that one.
Because he used to get really crowded you
know just what it is pack in there with
all these sweaty naked bodies everywhere
and the other one was built over a creek
and you could jump through a
hole in the floor into the creek
when youre hot enough.
A lot of street activity all the time.
A lot of the shops at that time in
yemen were unused just empty shop.
But during the first of all these
people came out of the woodwork
and set up things like a banana fitter
shops in just empty shop fronts
and things like a lot of street
theatre especially in the evening.
Most evenings in the
streets here to happening
and then of course there was
the great drama of the bust.
When the police arrested
somebody couple people i think
that were down in the camping area.
Supposedly for heroin possession
but by the time they got them from the
campsite up to the street with a paddy wagon
was there must have been at least 300
people had surrounded the paddy wagon.
The handcuffs were actually
cut off with bolt cutters.
And the guy escaped and a
policeman had his gun stolen.
Now the result of the gun being stolen was
that the next morning there would have
been perhaps 50 police in town all very
heavy very serious and wanting
to know where their gun was
and apparently it was returned
i don't know who returned it
or who would even taken it
but it was it was returned
and even the escapee returned as
well with a lawyer by his side
and everything calmed down considerably.
After that. What else.
What else i was actually living about
10 kilometres out of town at the
time we did travel in early every
morning i don't open up the kitchen
and get the porridge hot
and things like gather porridge hot. Yes.
So we were renting a
farm house at $5 a week.
I think we were paying and
when we arrived we had about 80 dollars
to our name so we immediately spent 50 on
advance rent just to make sure
that we wouldn't run out of
that.
No no it was a desire
to just to get sorry.
What brought into the festival was a
desire to get out into the country.
It had been i suppose part of the
alternative ethos at that time
that the end result was to leave the
city to get back to nature to go to the
country to grow your own vegetables
to build your own house.
Just to do it you know and
i'd tried once before.
Very briefly in kangaroo valley and that
had been a complete failure and ieds.
Got all back to sydney after only a few
weeks of us wondering how i'd cope with
leeches in the future.
And this was just this was.
It was just to be in the area i'd
lived at mullumbimby for a while
and there's a lot of people coming over
the nimbin and we kind of an imminent.
Lot of talk of let's settle
here and things like
that which is pretty much what
i did eventually yes i think
that was i mean it was it was just to be
in at the gathering of the clans it felt
like all your brothers and
sisters were coming along and.
That was where you should be.
Nimbin gee. Yes well.
I said.
I don't know what nimbin
gene means i'm sorry in.
The earth's spirit. I don't
know. I mean the word nim done.
Or nimbin i've heard a lot of.
I suppose an explanation for the name at
the time of the festival the prevailing
thought was that a nimbin
was like an aboriginal.
Wise man a holy man and. I've since heard
it's it's a spiritus or it's as well.
Apparently the area wasn't was never actually
lived in by the corys they came here
for the men and boys came here
for an initiation purposes
or for religious ceremonies
and then they went back to wherever they
lived i think they probably live closer to
the coast where there was more fishing is
that the bunch of young
people who were the product
but the minute tribe of the area
were. Very much into their fishing.
Coastal vise. Try by i mean they started
at bunge one when the old grandmother
and her sons arrived at the
beach at evans head there
and i think grandmother
and one of her son fell asleep on the
other ones went off looking for food
somewhere else and died and they
camped there on the hill at evans head
and started off.
So what exactly it means
i'm not sure except
that it probably has a lot to do with
with something reasonably sacred to
aborigines a name it sort of knew
lindsey was spelt like that.
I suspect just to give people a
lot of trouble in saying it.
The property was it was. Bought.
Probably about six months after
the first of all probably took
that long to get enough people together
with another finance to purchase it.
I think it was found before that
there was quite a land oppression
and properties for sale 1:50 remain
for sale for quite some time.
The idea of this particular property
and buying it and getting a community.
Happening here was the brainchild
of a man called brian joyce
and the woman who was
living with sue sue lane
and bryant came out looked
at the place took one look
and said yes this is the place for me
and get it together is many friends
and friends of friends and it was bought.
I wasn't one of the original
46 people i came in.
Probably no for you know
i mean i would think
when a couple of other
people had sold out.
And.
Well it's hard as they are brian's ideals
i don't know brian's ideals coincide with
every authority and i probably
didn't because he's gone. But.
His concept was of a community
of people that lived together.
Very closely.
A lot of close.
I would say intense interpersonal
reactions very much.
The encounter group type situation you
know your feeling shitty you say you're
giving a shit today. You know just
the way you're looking whatever.
It's it's not for a while.
Be very difficult y to live
permanently and i think he felt
that those ideal had been sacrificed
to other more pressing things like
shelter and water and
that people was spreading people building
houses separated away from the community
house and weren't being seen for
days at a time and things like that.
He never bothered with the house he just
moved into the old area that was here
and lived there and wasn't
interested in anything agricultural
or other or.
He was definitely a people person
and he went back to the city and.
Started a circus.
In terms of what and what. A reason.
Originally was sharing everything.
Originally are all food was bought
just as a big bowl shop the at the
community house there was a.
Large pantries now the office.
Funny how things change where the filing
cabinet is now they used to be big bins
full of grains
and there was an attitude then
of trying to be agriculturally
self-sufficient. That's never really
eventuated the soil is not great.
And the people who are coming to live here
weren't really destined to be farmers
around thing.
With one of them were very people orientated
as well because social interactions
always been a very large
part of this community.
I suppose most communities
do when you're living
and sharing a lot of
facilities with people.
It's industry them and talk to them
and whatever fight with them.
So it's.
It's been a very a very sort of organic
process the change. Once again primarily.
To do with who was here at any given time
and the type of person they
were whether they were.
A dominant type of personality or
had very strong ideas and attitudes
and they want to do particular things our
motivated you know i think if you've got
people that are very motivated
to do a particular thing
and can express their ideas well then.
Other people who perhaps aren't
so motivated can think with that.
Yeah that's a good way to go
destroy that. I mean. My lap.
And mainly.
One of the big things is everyone building
houses you know obviously getting
individual shelter situation
especially as more
and more people started
having families and
when the people first bought the
property there was no children involved.
One of the shareholders was pregnant
and she had her child here on the
property up in the community house there.
And since then there's been i think
15 children born on the property.
So yeah.
As people tended to have families perhaps
break up into more traditional nuclear
family situations they built
themself nuclear family style houses
in various spots around the property that
no one as yet has actually sort of guilt.
A group type of living situation you know
a number of for example single people
building a place together
and and sharing it.
A person like to see more
of them that. I haven't.
I've got the wife and the two children.
Everything according
to the city's 6 1 dog.
Yes.
Bush.
It has it has because it had been a
bush experience of a nuclear power
but not totally.
Had it been a bush experience of the nuclear
family in some respects yes it has i
mean i've got a house
and we've got you know a veggie
garden next to the house. But.
There's a large community vegetable
garden happening as well
that a lot of the single people who are
here right now it's been a bit of a
population shift of light.
A number of the. All the people
have all the shareholders.
More regional shareholders perhaps the
original shows rather than older. And down.
I just feel like
that have moved to lose more education
actually had a lot to do with that.
There's no final he is living
in 12 in the knees yet so
that the nearest high schools
if you've got children
that are going on the year
11 and 12 is in lismore
and it's obviously a damn sight easier
to go to high school isn't with you.
Living it is more rather than
travel 60 or 70 caged on a bus.
So that's been a factor.
I guess is there are other factors
to diss wishing for more.
Creature comforts perhaps
so wanting to. Have.
A job that requires you being working
in lismore or elsewhere. Every day.
If not the most convenient place to travel
to and from on a regular basis out here.
I mean can be done just want to
wear and tear on your vehicle.
The nuclear family in the bush this still
a lot of facilities that are shared.
For example. Most people still do all
their washing in the community laundry.
There are only a couple of pumping
systems that provide water.
To the whole community. You know
so that example if the pump.
Breaks down even though i
mightn't be the one that's using
that particular pump i mop it
once it goes down and fixes it.
Not that i'm saying i'm always thinking
that but i do i do fix the fun thing
and again all the washing machines
are things like that are so
and in terms of.
The normal for example bills and debt
that a nuclear family living alone on in
their own piece of land would incur that's
something that i haven't had to live with
for example you know the rights and.
Land taxes for example all
that sort of stuff that's part of just
everyone pays a certain amount to the
co-operative every year and that
covers all those types of bills so.
Sharing certain things. Yes
and having your own as well.
Definitely been financial benefits i mean
i couldn't of been unemployed for a good
many years and i certainly
couldn't have heard of.
Created this life almost
for myself unless.
I could have shared with other people.
I suppose it was never a
stated goal originally
but i suppose everybody would
have liked to would have had that
that concept did to be able to somehow
be become economically independent
and live this lifestyle is just
finding the way to doing it you know
i'm still looking.
I think. Group. As a.
No not really not on this particular
community i mean other communities.
I think have a perhaps more of a group
consciousness towards finance rising in and.
Economic viability perhaps and it's.
I mean community did a really just a
product of the sum total of the people who
happen to partake of them and specially
with not so much because it's so large
and it drew from such a a large
sort of database or person based
when it originally set up it's got.
Factions of all shapes sizes and colors
but a number of the other
all the communities.
Probably will started primarily
from a group of known friends.
You know and known friends are usually
people with similar ideas and attitudes
and aspirations do you usually you know
within certain boundaries of i think of the
very middle class community with a lot of
people coming from generally middle class
type backgrounds and probably lots
of holding a lot of middle class.
Asians an idea deep down underneath.
I mean i know the community.
I've been back as well where almost
every shareholder school teacher.
And they are very educationally involved.
Fantastic fantastic.
I can't think of a better place in terms
of some way to bring up one's children.
I really can't think of a better place.
Overall in terms of having having an
environment where your children can
not come home necessarily from
the school bus in the afternoon
and you won't see them till dark
and yet you're not in the slightest bit
worried as to where they've gone they can
be with somebody else on the community
you know of playing with some friends
or going to somebody else's place that's
that's a lot of things is obviously great
you know the children got a degree of
freedom. Perhaps and i suppose innocence.
You know but a degree of freedom
that these days. I don't think is.
Is possible in the urban environment.
They've learnt to grow up with some.
What i consider good healthy attitudes
towards the environment they take
environmental issues just
so much for granted.
You know of course you don't rubbish
things of course you don't do this
and of course you don't do that you know.
Whereas out of here that we've
had to learn or take on board.
You know for them it's just the way
it is and they've got i don't know.
I don't have a normal
aspiration if under some has
that won't want to get out there
and make a million bucks get rich
come home go to their father.
Others don't. My my children.
At this stage is still a bit.
They're only just turning teenagers and
they haven't got any firm and fixed
that attitude as to what they'd like to
really do themselves. Once i finish school.
But i've seen a number
of children grow up here
and leave as what i consider
good adults you know like.
Interesting people good
attitudes do well it's cool.
I certainly haven't. Well you know.
The people who haven't tried to.
Anyway sort of style.
If i education as such.
Well not the children here have gone.
Of all gone to the local public primary
school back as well which is a
very nice little countries go
nowhere near town about 100 people
for teachers just a very good school.
It's got an enormous amount of
community input into from the parents.
It's perhaps the best of both worlds.
You know it's free public education
and it's got enough external
input that there are.
That. I don't know it's.
Off as a lot of schools have parents input
it just seems to have a lot of very
positive hearing when but they have a.
Things like oh cultural options which
is when parents will come along
and one day a week for
maybe a month or six weeks
and take a small group of
children in a particular.
Anything i just it's a group of kids
making windchimes out of all forks
and spoons and another woman
did felt making and just just.
Skills things like that.
And opportunities for
kids to learn things like
a favorite nimbin the story. The.
Ah.
I'll ponder that one ask
me another question
and i well i think i had to put the
pause button on five newman's change.
A sense of place in the now i really
feel proud to say you know i'm from them
and you're through i come from
years ago i say i'm from.
Barker's violence between
chi ogle no will no.
But now i'm from nimbin just
out of nimbin actually yeah.
No it was it was the people
thing that drew drew me here
that i was particularly attracted to just
the idea of settling in an area with
lots of like minded people
you know kith and kin.
And creating a community where you felt
like you weren't one of the minority
but that but that you were
one of the establishment.
Even though it was your own establishment.
I think that's still what is perhaps my
strongest feeling about newman you know
especially of being a wife a little bit my
drive back in there today even for a few
days you drive into town. It's just
so different from anywhere else.
You know anything. How and
then then home again you know
and there's total out of it.
There are leagues collapsed in front of
the hot bread shop there was yes i was
wonderful.
Right at their doorstep you said that
their mattresses check hadn't come in
and the usual cluster outside
the rainbow and just.
Just all sorts of characters you know
people are in really disreputable baggy old
tights wandering along. Yeah
just just the colour and.
The non-conformist well it's pretty
conforming within isn't it. I mean really.
I simply like it
when the rat pack came to town with with
their shredded clothes in their dreadlocks
to their knees and things
like oh wonderful looking
and i like it visually
visually exciting them
and i like a like the whole aspect
of change to a like the fact
that there's all these things happening
this is permaculture village i really hope
kicks off in them and just because it
will mean yet another group of people
and more change and i enjoy change.
You know it's not always for
the best but i just like
that dynamics of it not just
being something stagnant
that we're whole lot of
all hippies went to die.
But somewhere where a whole lot of new
hippies are coming to live as well you know
i like seeing the young people
not as hippies as people.
I mean this is lots of a lot of people
around here these are in a place
that have moved in them and for
whatever reasons. Good solid people.
Yes well.
There are a few challenges from them
and i think the sewerage one of the
big challenges is it and for that.